all day we've been asking for your
questions uh relating to rishi's relaxed
large yes if you can call it that uh we
i say got so many questions well with me
to answer them are miata fanboolay ceo
of the new economics foundation personal
finance expert gemma godfrey they're
here with me in the studio and anna
stevenson senior welfare benefits
specialist at the charity turn to us
very welcome to you all thank you very
much indeed we have as i just said there
got loads and loads of questions so i'm
going to plow straight into them some of
them specific some of them a bit more
general so our first question is this
and i suppose it's one that so many
people have is the relief for energy
costs going to be
means tested well let me start with you
then anna um
is the answer to that i mean i'm
starting it off is is it kind of yes and
no
yes and no or a little bit of it depends
um there have been a few different
schemes announced today um the really
really big one is universal that's 400
pounds of winter energy bills for
everyone who's paying an energy bill so
that one's definitely not means tested
um we've got extra help for pensioners
that's not means tested that's based on
your age we've got extra help for
disabled people it's not means tested
but it's based on getting
non-means-tested disability benefits
things like attendance allowance or
personal independence payment
and then there's additional targeted
support 650 pound payment for people who
are on means-tested benefits but
technically that's not means tested it
will be 650 pounds regardless of whether
you're towards the top of the universal
credit income scale or towards the
bottom but it's based on getting one of
those means tested benefits
okay so that's clear and leads into the
next question i'm going to stay with you
on that and event so what are the income
thresholds for these payments and and
how are they being paid how will people
get them you're already telling us that
um when it comes to the we've called it
means tested but they're shadowing the
universal credit thresholds
yeah so these are based on you getting
one of the means tested benefits so
that's universal credit that's pension
credit income support income related
employment and support allowance income
related job seekers allowance child tax
credits working tax credits this big set
of means-tested benefits
now i can't give you an easy
income threshold because these benefits
are based on your circumstances what you
can really easily do is go to the turn
towards website and do a free benefit
calculator to check if you could be
getting any of these benefits they are
really under claimed especially pension
credit
so um there's not an income threshold
but they're based on these means tested
benefits
in terms of how they're being paid
they're going to be paid automatically
to people who are receiving those
benefits the assumption is that be paid
through the same means that you get your
benefits so if you get your benefit by a
direct transfer that will be how you get
it which most people do so i'll come
straight in right well let's concentrate
on our next question which is asking
about the 400 pounds that nearly all
households are getting and this question
asks uh
there you are uh when is the 400 pounds
aid likely to be given to customers
if it is in october as predicted how
will this help people that are already
in fuel debt now miata i mean because of
course you know the uh the cap already
went up substantially over 600 pounds in
april and so quite a long time to wait
well it is a long time away well the cap
went up by between 680 800 pounds we're
expecting it to go up by another 800
pounds in october
so this 400 pounds will help it's going
to go to energy companies that in that
should
take it off your bill there's a bit of
trust there but they should take it off
your bill but in truth for a lot of
people it just won't be enough um it
will it will take the sting off but
you're still seeing a whopping 1 100
pounds that you're having to suck up
this year yeah on top of rising prices
for food and other things um
so
it helps but not as much as it does and
just what about this issue of the the
non-targeted nature of the of the 400
pounds i mean you know is that an
efficient use of funds which are pretty
sure um the short answer is no i think
they were thinking about the easiest and
quickest way so just give it to everyone
and give it to the energy companies and
you don't have to deal with the admin
my view is that they probably should
have raised the win full tax by a bit
more and got a little bit more money and
then targeted those
in the middle that don't get benefits
but are really struggling that's just a
very very good point you're anticipating
our next question because so many
millions of people will be asking that
saying well okay you know i don't get
universal credit but boy are we
struggling here's the question uh what
help is available to people who aren't
entitled to universal credit anna
what help is available elsewhere i mean
do we do we know
i'm sorry gemma no it's fine it's fine
um so i mean this is the big problem
exactly with with some of the
government's measures and we saw this
when the government came out with
furlough which was that people would
fall through the cracks and it's great
to have and it's incredibly important to
support people that are on benefits and
it's easier to identify them but you
have a whole raft of people that
are working really hard don't qualify
for the benefit support and they're not
going to be able to see as much support
as they need to if you also look at some
of the some of the measures that came
out certain you know council tax rebates
came in but again only for certain
households so the government's kind of
tried this act of you know give
everybody a certain level of support
that isn't targeted enough and then
targeted level of support at the bottom
end and there are just millions of
people that are just not going to yeah
it's beneficial i mean but that that is
the issue isn't it where do you draw the
lines and we've got so many questions
about that here's uh here's our next one
uh
again about lines i suppose if the
winter fuel allowance is currently
shared between two state pensioners
living together as a couple will the 300
pounds extra payment also be shared that
is one for you anna so
two pensioners living together
um how is the money divvied up and is it
cut
uh yes from the information we've
received from the treasury so far it
looks like that 300 pound payment is for
a household not for an individual
okay very clear and that's all the
answer we need another question does
today's announcement mean the original
200 pounds help in october will not have
to be paid back through our energy bills
gemma yeah because people
you know people i suppose really didn't
quite understand that that 200 pounds
was going to be clawed back over what
was it was five years or something it
wasn't
well that was the whole issue they were
they were came out and announced here
you go you have 200 pounds and then the
small print was you have to pay it back
and actually it wasn't over a long
enough period that we think the energy
prices are going to be able to adjust
backwards so um so they have come out
today because of the backlash really and
they've said okay they're going to
double the allowance of 400 pounds and
you don't have to pay it back which
otherwise would have been madness the
other thing wasn't it about the about
the 200 pounds was it was about the
household and the bill so if you moved
house if you were renting or whatever or
shared house well then you know somebody
else who moves in has to pay it back it
would have been an administrative
nightmare which would have cost us
millions
okay um this windfall tax then on excess
profits as defined doesn't impact
households this is the question why
won't the energy cap be reinstated if
it's obvious the energy suppliers are
reaping the majority of the awards miata
what are your thoughts on that well so
in the government to be fair to the
government where the big excess profits
are being made are the energy generators
the people who are supplying us are sort
of retailers people like british grass
um edf have actually they are being
squeezed because they're the ones that
are sort of they have the cap that's
sort of bearing down um on
the cost that they can pass on so for me
what the government should have done is
say look let's properly tax those that
are making excess profits and let's use
that to cushion consumers and they did
that a little bit hence why we've got
the 400 but not enough properly taxed so
what would you like to have seen well so
the the numbers we were talking about is
tax 70 percent
which they they ended up doing about 65
percent taxed 70 but without this um tax
deduction a lot of relief yeah there's a
lot of relief that basically takes most
of it away that would have raised about
13 billion and then use that 13 billion
to help the squeeze middle but i also
think there's another thing that they
could have done which is one of the
reasons we're in this problem is because
a lot of suppliers also went bust and
there isn't enough competition in the
market so a lot of people have been
asking you know should they go around
and check for a better deal and there's
just not enough competition so actually
what you also need to see is some
support for smaller providers to bring
competition back into the market as well
okay got another quick one before we
need to take a break anna um short and
sweet if you can what help will there be
for people like me that can't go to work
due to illness will there be extra help
for the disabled community
there will yes so particularly if you're
getting personal independence payment
adult disability payment attendance
allowance disability living allowance
um sorry i know it's a big long list but
you won't be getting all of them um if
you're getting any of those benefits
there'll be an extra 150 pound one-off
payment in december um it's likely you
may also be able to benefit from some of
the other schemes as well because all
these schemes are cumulative that's
important to remember so you'll get 150
pounds and you'll get the 400 pounds and
if you're on means tested benefits
you'll get the 650 pounds and if you're
a pensioner the winter fuel allowance
yes yes exactly it'll all
round up to add extra extra extra
support for people who have these
multiple layers of vulnerability okay
that that's really useful advice thank
you all very much indeed so far but yeah
you're staying with me for quite a long
time we're going to take a short break
you're watching a question and answer
program about the cost of living so do
stay with us because we'll be tackling
more of your incredibly important
questions right after the break stay
with us
[Music]
well joining me tonight to answer your
questions about the cost of living army
out of van boule ceo of the new
economics foundation personal finance
expert gemma godfrey and anna stevenson
senior welfare benefits specialist at
the charity turn to us so we have all
the talented brains trust here let's get
into your questions and
this one asks low-income families need
instant support how do you believe a
rise in winter fuel payments which won't
kick in until next year will help
struggling and vulnerable people miata
again we
address this slightly with the other
payments but it is
it's the gap it's the lag it is the lag
um it is the lag and i think a lot of
people are already under pressure uh to
be fair some of it will kick in early in
the autumn but i think where we will get
to is that people get to the back end of
this year and they will just be under
phenomenal pressure let's and the key
thing to say is what we're seeing at the
moment is the impact of rising price
energy prices we know that's going to
have a knock-on effect on everything
else it's having a knock-on effect on
food it's having a knock-on effect on
everyday household essentials and then
you have the ukraine impact so i think
we're about to see quite a hefty hit
this autumn winter and at the moment
they've taken the sting out the tail but
they haven't really resolved that issue
let's talk about that hefty hit because
our next question addresses that and now
i i did not know this this is a
householder who says that my energy
summary for the next 12 months forecast
that my energy bill will more than
double my goodness me what are the
government doing with the extra vat that
they will receive from us of course
gemini they
raking in a lot of extra vat because you
know that hasn't gone or does it five
percent on energy absolutely i think one
of the things that there was a lot of
pressure for the government to do was
cut v80 because if there's a windfall
tax on the energy energy uh providers
then
likewise they're getting a windfall from
the vat obviously the way the
government's positioning this is the v80
that they make will then be funneled
back into the benefits and i think if
you actually look at everything they've
done today their total uh budget it
brings it to 37 billion pounds that
they've been using to support families
so that's what they're going to be doing
but obviously it's not as targeted as it
should be it's late in the game and at
this point you know if you have energy
prices as high as that one of the things
we haven't mentioned is debt if people
fall into debt then obviously you've got
a debt burden if interest rates go up as
they are then the price of having that
debt burden continues to go up and
people then fall further and further
under the cost it applies to governments
as well doesn't it because the
government's debt burden their
repayments i mean they're eye-watering
at the moment well so the key thing to
say is not just vat the government has
had a massive boon in tax receipts
because of inflation so if we think back
to the spring statement the thing that
was very clear is the government was
getting more money than expected it was
paying down its deficit quicker than
expected it's due to make a surplus next
year so he had quite a lot of headroom
and for me i wanted to see more of that
headroom yes there was targeted support
for low-income families for example but
it's a one-off payment why are we not
rebuilding our social security safety
net the reason why a lot of people are
at the point where they're not eating or
heating is because we've hacked away at
benefits for about 10 years and so they
were already on the bread line and then
you chuck the shock and that's what
happened so that
should have been used to build our
resilience not just for this winter but
for next year and the year after and
that's what he has the space to do with
that tack spoon and he hasn't chosen to
do that yeah here's the crystal ball
question who wants to stick their neck
out how sorry what do you think will
happen
to gas and electricity prices over the
next two years well miata you know we
mentioned
the war in ukraine who knows how long
that will last but even with or without
it well energy just seems to be going up
and up yeah so all the predictions are
we're likely to see this for another 12
to 18 months um and there is you know
part of the problem is there are
external forces but also our energy
market is quite broken uh so when you
look at wholesale prices they've
actually all dropped but a lot of the
energy providers bought in future
markets at high prices so consumers are
bearing the brunt of that i think it's
going to take us a couple of years for
this to shake out and i hope in that
time the government isn't just providing
short-term support but it's thinking
about how do we get this broken market
to actually work for consumers because
of the women in this market yeah and
i've got a couple of questions for you
um let's have a look at this one i
support the government giving help to
those with benefits however
i am a single person who works and have
a lower income the cost of energy food
and fuel is pushing me into serious
financial crisis what help is there for
me a single person who works and has a
low income and of course all those costs
going up what help
so this can be really challenging um
single people don't get the same work
allowances the same additional support
that you see in universal credit for
families and so that can mean that it is
much much harder to support the income
of single people
it is still worth a lot of people just
assume that they can't get benefits it
is still worth doing a benefit
calculator seeing if there is any help
they can get
um they will get this 400 pound off
their energy bills in the winter
it is still worth shopping around on
your other utilities to see if there is
any money you can save
but
they are at the moment the group of
people who are the most challenging to
support and it's not just central
government that has funds isn't it local
authorities have been given relief funds
as well you can sometimes access them
they have yeah local authorities have
been given extra funding to provide
discretionary support for people who are
in crisis but we haven't yet seen the
terms of these schemes
what we have seen when these
when there are equivalent schemes last
winter and the winter before was that
they tended to target families with
children and people with disabilities
because they tend to be the people who
get the very worst outcomes when things
go wrong and this council tax rebate
next question um the question is why is
the government just giving that on bands
a to d is there any chance of that being
expanded or extended
so this banzai to d thing this is
exactly the problem that miata was
talking about earlier that it's really
really hard in our current data to
target middle income households it's
quite easy to identify the very lowest
income households but the government was
trying to provide semi-targeted support
towards middle-income households and
they went with council tax as the
mechanism to do that
um there is discretionary funding that's
been given to councils for people who
are in higher council tax plans but who
didn't qualify for the um 150 pound
council tax rebate and who are in crisis
so if you're really struggling do
approach your council about that
as in so many cases in life that data
really matters the quality and the
quantity um last question to squeeze in
in this section gemma this is really
getting you to stick your neck out right
i heard you as you read it there is now
a good time to get a mortgage who knows
i'm not going to say yes or no let me
explain what hold you to it how to
decide so first of all the context is is
that interest rates have been creeping
up and they're at one percent and yes
it's the highest of 13 years but it's
been an unprecedented period and
actually if you look at it in 1992
interest rates were over 10
so there's a huge amount that they could
continue to rise so the three things to
think about are if you want to get a
mortgage i mean ultimately if you're
going to get a mortgage because you're
looking to buy a property you know and
you'll need one to buy one but the three
things to think about are number one
about paying for the privilege of fixing
your mortgage right and to protect you
from higher interest rates um but you
will have to pay so to make sure that
that's actually worth your while
secondly consider when you'll want to
move because again a mortgage the term
of the mortgage there'll be early
repayments fees if you want to move
within that time and thirdly
affordability is a really key issue that
actually mortgage lenders are much more
focused on adding three percent to the
current in like their highest rate at
the moment and working out whether if
the rate was three percent higher
whether you could still afford it is
there also a guess though for anyone
buying into property now about the
possible impact of a recession on house
prices because you know whether you get
a good deal on your mortgage or not if
you're losing equity in your home it
doesn't really matter what rate you're
paying you don't like it it's not good
for you i always say that buying a house
is more i mean it's a it's it's not
really we call it an investment but it's
really somewhere that you live and if
you really want to make money out of out
of property with all the costs of moving
and selling all this stuff that actually
it's more about okay are you going to
rent or is it better value if you
actually buy now what can you afford how
long do you want to live there are you
raising a family all these other things
i think come to play very important okay
taking a break as i say you're watching
a special question and answer program
about the cost of living stay with us
next up amongst the questions we'll be
addressing the issue of whether all this
extra money in the economy will prove to
be inflationary stay with us
[Music]
as you probably know by now joining me
tonight to answer your questions about
the cost of living our miata fanboule
ceo of the new economics foundation
personal finance expert gemma godfrey
and anna stevenson senior welfare
benefits specialist with the charity
turn to us we're going to turn to more
of your questions
this one concerning help for businesses
and through them help for employees is
there a way to support businesses by
giving employees a pay rise to help with
this increasing inflation what nine ten
percent at the moment uh miata well i
suppose there's the the minimum wage the
the living wage
there is there is the um national living
wage which the chancellor to be fair did
increase i think the key thing is
the living wage ought to reflect the
true cost of living and at the moment it
doesn't um so he increased it to about
nine nine pounds fifty um outside of
london uh and the we know that with
inflation that level should be much
higher um i do think there is a piece
around where we build that it's tough
for
businesses as well at the moment
but actually trying to get to people
where you're earning an income that
allows you to afford the cost of living
must be the objective in all of this and
just a big picture question mentioning
inflation in terms of the economy
overall now
i'm not an expert you are but isn't
putting lots of money into the economy
a risk when inflation is already rising
you know i mean people need the money to
spend but that then starts perhaps
pushing up inflation even more well
there is a risk but i think the key
thing is to remember what's driving
inflation so the big drivers inflation
are imported it's kind of global
pressures energy supply chain etc it's
not the fact that the demand is
overheating the economy is overheating
there's lots of demand so actually we we
we are on the cusp of recession which
means that demand is actually falling so
giving money to particularly to people
at the lower end who will spend it in
their local economies on essential
things i don't think it's going to spike
up inflation i think of anything it's
going to potentially help us stem the
worst impacts of recession so it's the
cause of inflation so it's really these
supply chain blockages at the moment
exactly thank you very much indeed for
that another question then i'll put this
one to you gemma my fixed rate deal with
scottish power finishes at the end of
the month going from get this 80 pounds
to 400 pounds multiple of five per month
what is the best thing to do i mean that
is an incredible increase what's your
advice i mean the real challenge is the
traditional advice would be shop around
uh shop around try and get the best deal
but you can't at the moment because
actually a lot of suppliers went bust
and there isn't as much um competition
in the market and also they're savvy
supplies are savvy and you have to pay
for the privilege of fixing it at a
certain rate and the concern is is that
you may actually be paying too much
at the moment in time because there's so
little choice out there people are so
fearful so actually it's some in some
respects some of the best advice is
actually wait and see which is a
horrible thing to say but really i think
there are so many families out there
that are struggling that are doing what
they can they're putting pressure on
saying that there may be a better deal
out there is honestly so i mean you know
do you really have to take the money the
government's giving you and cross your
fingers and hope okay the price cap we
know is going up again in october and
when it's reviewed by
april 2023 that it starts to dip that's
all you can do well the problem is what
are the alternatives to that so it is
about making sure that you're getting
the right government support but
absolutely with the fact that the energy
cap is bound to go up energy suppliers
know that and therefore there's going to
be no fixed rate that will protect you
from that it is a very tough time okay
uh next question this one again about
pensioners what happened
to the triple lot for pensioners have
the government gone back on their
promise well anna i know a bit about
that well um yeah a bit uh tell us more
so the triple lock is a policy that um
guaranteed that pensions would go up by
at least
certain averages so um
there were three different rules and it
would go up by the lowest of them um the
government has slightly abandoned its
promise on one of those because one of
those was average earnings and when
average earnings went very peculiar
during the pandemic
the
government took the decision that they
would not be operating pensions in line
with average earnings
for a bit um the other issue is that
they have gone up in line with inflation
the trouble is that the rules by which
uh benefits and pensions are operated in
line with inflation it uses the
inflation rate in september to set the
amount they'll go up in april and of
course this year we saw inflation jump
enormously between september and april
and so that
um
increase the matched inflation back in
september by april was doing nothing and
by this winter we'll be doing absolutely
nothing
um
and so the hope had been and had been a
lot of calls on chancellor to make an
emergency up rating of benefits in line
with current inflation
the chancellor has not chosen to do that
and has chosen instead to use these
multiple different one-off payments
okay i see what you mean yes so so they
could fast forward that but it doesn't
seem they are going to at the moment
more on energy costs and this about the
green levy within everyone's bills um
the question is why can't this be
removed or at least reduced miata i mean
that's not just then about the money
that's about that the long term and
ultimately about the climate crisis so
it's a false economy because we have to
remember what this is paying for it's
paying for things like energy efficiency
which ironically is the thing that will
get down the cost of bills
for the long term it's also paying for
you know different types of kind of
renewables and that transition that we
need to make which again will help with
our security so getting rid of it is the
wrong temporarily though just above what
i do think the government should do is
take it off bills in the way it is and
puts it into general taxation because
it's a far more progressive way to do it
at the moment people at the bottom end
will pay more because they tend to pay
their energy bills tend to be a bigger
chunk of their income so i'm actually
all for removing it from levies it was
never for me a good way to do it can i
throw in then you know what about vat as
well you know that was meant to be that
was meant to be a brexit bonus not
allowed to do it under the eu this the
government can now do it but it hasn't
it hasn't done it but to be fair to them
the you know if you
removing vat would be about
hundred odd quid um so in the grand
scale of the support that people need it
probably is sort of tinkering around the
margins um and it isn't targeted so
actually trying to get uh cash payments
for that middle is a far better way to
do it okay here's another specific
question but it does concern the green
ambitions the green necessity for us all
um why is hmrc not increase the pence
per mile for company car drivers of
electric cars the price cap went up 50
percent on electric yet the rate i can
claim from my employer is still only
five p a mile and who knows about this
gemma i mean you know there's basically
a bigger gap growing up again in this
area and i think this is a fantastic
question and obviously it doesn't have
an easy answer because why
the answer is that the government should
have been able to um make sure that
people that are deciding to to make
greener decisions are going to be better
for our economy and our on move to net
zero and having more renewable sources
of energy and less reliance and lower
energy bills people who are able to do
that and helping us should get more
support and they're not and and that's
really my big concern is is that again
it's like when full taxes on oil and gas
producers but they'll give them tax
relief what about all the other
alternatives that will make our supply
much stronger okay there are always
consequences aren't there um oh now
we've got a couple of minutes left so
let's get a couple more questions in
anna um try this for size shouldn't the
energy providers be reducing the cost on
pre-pay meters or apply credits for
people because pre-pay meters i mean
awfully
often it's the people who can least
afford it on pre-pay meters and they're
paying higher rates
yeah um there is a higher energy price
cap for prepay customers the
justification for that has been that it
costs a little bit more to run the
infrastructure but this is a really
major problem that disproportionately
affects the lowest income households
um it is very very important that they
are considered very carefully through
this winter because what happens
is that they just self-disconnect this
is the the mild term that gets applied
to it what that means is they don't have
any money to put in the meter and so
they just sit there in the cold in the
dark
and it ends up being somewhat invisible
in a way that um whereas you know
people people who pre-pay who pay with
um who get energy bills
they
can run up debt and still stay connected
to their electricity for quite a long
time whereas pre-pay meters the whole
point is that you can't but that causes
immense suffering to people on the
lowest incomes so it is really important
to make sure that these people are
protected through this winter yeah off
gems should do something about that
certainly um let's get one last in
before our last break um why is our
government making energy prices so high
when other countries in europe haven't
seen the same increases
miata well i suppose is that all about
sources of supply and storage
well so that that's a million dollar
question and i think it comes back to
the market um and i think it comes back
to the fact that the market isn't
working so if you look across to france
there they've got a public sector
provider um edf it's owned uh by
citizens and the governments basically
say you take the hit you take the hit
and actually the rises we've seen of
about four percent compared to what
we're seeing here
so different countries have different
ways in which they're supplying energy i
think the way that we have it is very
very broken and consumers have long paid
the price of that and they're paying the
price again and so in all of this there
is a big reform story when we get onto
the other side of this it's like how do
you break up that market and by the way
use the opportunities of bringing in
more renewables to diversify that market
to build up our security and i would say
have more of that market owned by people
like me and you through cooperatives
through community um owned energy in a
way that's far more democratic and that
works in our interests rather than the
interests of those so generally we in
this country got the worst of all worlds
you know we had you know multiplicity of
providers as you described earlier lots
of them have gone bust which leads us to
the pickle wherein would it be better
you not wrongly out of them in the end
well let's get back to to a big
people-owned supplier and we can look
after the prices ourselves we just
multiple people and personally yeah well
we need to have multiple dynamics and i
think that's the problem there's not
much that we can do to be able to help
bring more security to our energy
markets
good good break coming up um you're
watching a special question and answer
program about the cost of living do stay
with us after the break we're going to
be asking about any plans to help
first-time buyer statements
[Music]
joining me tonight to answer your
questions about the cost of living
crisis are you know them all by now a
panel of experts they really are experts
so let's uh rather than me introducing
them again let's get some more questions
in because we have had so many from you
this is very short gemma are there any
plans to help first-time buyers well
there are already quite a few schemes
around aren't they i mean there are
already so in terms of is that any new
news the answer is no well what are the
existing ones talk to us i mean well you
have you have things like um you had
license you know lifetime isis the
ability to be able to save and if you
save um for a certain number of years
then obviously the government will then
provide you a certain level of savings
to match that the amount that you've
saved to put towards a deposit and if
you don't use that then it would go
towards a pension so been a few things
out there but i think the big challenge
for first-time buyers is first of all is
the fact that it's
a bigger deposit is now needed that a
lot of mortgage providers are actually
getting a little bit more savvy and the
affordability level is getting higher
and higher also the thing that has
changed as well as there has been a
period where the average cost of a
mortgage per month was cheaper than rent
and actually for the first time that's
now reversed so you know and again
interest rates are going up so i think
there's about three quarters of um
people that are on mortgages and haven't
fixed them you know this is a real issue
for people in the market at the moment
do you think though if the housing
market
starts to stall or shows the appearance
of doing that that the government might
bring in you know stamp duty holidays
again or something like that i mean it's
a very easy lever for them to pull and
it's something they've done before
because i think the big cohort that
we're talking about now are the first
time buyers because of course people are
already in the property market well then
they'll benefit yes they may sell lower
but they'll also buy lower but i think
if there's a problem with the property
market stagnating and they need to keep
that going then that's something they're
going to do let's talk now a bit more
about the targeting of this money and
it's very straightforward question why
not contribute to a minimum wage
increase instead anna what are your
thoughts
about that well
that really does help people in work who
just don't earn very much
it does but
the people who are the most vulnerable
to rising energy bills are pensioners
and people who are disabled and can't
work and an increase in minimum wage
wouldn't do anything to help them
okay miata you know i've seen i mean we
talked about the living wage the minimum
wage yeah so look in the end the
priority has to be those at the sharp
end of it but i think there are many
people on minimum wage who will also be
on universal credit um and will uh
benefit but you know there is a piece in
all of this about how we get raises to
rise to keep up with the cost of living
particularly at the bottom end and we
haven't got that right yet yeah and
isn't also the issue is about looking at
it long term some a lot of the time it's
about let's make sure that i mean a lot
of employers are under a lot of pressure
and i think also what we want to do is
try and stimulate the economy create
more job creation and you know certain
measures that might put them under
pressure to make make people redundant
because they can't afford them anymore i
think would be around they've already
had that national insurance increase as
well um which seems to be being
overlooked um right long-term plan well
this is a good question is there any
sign of a long-term plan in this
announcement it'll help this winter no
doubt but isn't this just a sticking
plaster when we need stitches or as uh
some in government say when we need
surgery um miata long term plan yeah
there's no long term plan in sight this
is a sticking plaster intervention which
by the way we needed a bit of sticking
plaster because it was so dire and it
was completely frustrating that the
chancellor moved as slowly as he did but
this gets us through the autumn
and beyond that not much else which is
why for me there should have been a
measure that was focused on bolstering
social security because we build that
resilience in the long term and we're
still waiting for that we needed to
seize things around energy efficiency
great homes upgraded imagine if we had a
national effort that said we're going to
insulate millions of homes over the
course of the next three years to bear
down on bills and then you move to
reform agenda and say look how do we get
wages up how do we get markets that you
know should be working for people not
working for people and there was none of
that so they've done enough to help
people in the short term
to live another day but they've not now
strategy
different perspectives i know from you
all on all of this staying with this
question anna what's your take on that
does it seem you know more or less
reactive rather than proactive no
evidence of a really detailed plan
yeah i mean it's positive that the
chancellor has recognized that the
social security system is a useful way
of targeting support to the lowest
income households but we have seen 10
years of benefit freezes and changes in
welfare policy that have just eaten and
eaten away at the financial resilience
of households and so now we're in a
situation where we lurch from crisis to
crisis we had covert we had emergency
measures put in and then we had
inflation we had emergency measures
within and then they weren't enough and
we have some more emergency measures
within and this lurching from crisis
crisis is no good for the economy it's
no good for the country it's no good for
the lowest income people it just doesn't
work we need a welfare benefit system
that enables people to live and thrive
and participate fully in society
anna do you detect strategy here or
reaction well i think absolutely it's
reactive and i think one of the other
things is if you look at the reasons why
we've got higher inflation it's also
because of supply chain issues you had
brexit you've had people because of
covered going back to other countries
you've got more restriction around free
workforces there are all these other
dynamics that are in play that and none
of them you know we talk about it's like
it's like if somebody's ill and we're
only looking at the symptoms we're not
looking at the cause and yes we need to
prop up people but what are we doing to
actually help stem the problem so that
in a couple of years time that these
things can readjust and i can't see any
strategy there but of course there is so
much uncertainty out there to to be fair
to anyone trying to come up with
long-term plans and uh
this is one of the the major challenges
well not just for for europe certainly
for ukraine but for the entire world um
if the war in ukraine ends will the cost
of living decrease again how long would
it take to feel an impact well you know
who knows but miata what what's the
feeling
will the cost of living decrease if we
can end that conflict if um well the
russians can be removed from ukraine
that's our hope but i think the key
point to say is that it will mean it
doesn't get worse so the cost of living
crisis was there even before ukraine and
there was a consequence of brexit i know
we're not allowed to talk about it
anymore but it was a consequence of
brexit it was a consequence of supply
bottlenecks coming out of the pandemic
some of which still haven't gone away
and it was a consequence of supply
pressures here you know we don't have an
energy
enough to energy security in this
country so there were all these
fundamental problems anyway and then you
threw in the war in ukraine so i think
we haven't fully felt the impact of the
warning we can we're starting to feel it
on things like food prices and energy on
the margins but it could get worse so
for me
it just means it doesn't get worse okay
worse before it gets better and we don't
know when that might happen last
question really interesting to get all
your takes on that have to be fairly
brief because we're nearly out of time
are these policies just delaying an
inevitable recession oh
gemma i mean the the challenge that we
have is that a lot of families are
struggling and they're fighting a war on
multiple fronts and that i think is
that's why uh otherwise we would be
heading towards a recession so for
example you've got food prices going up
you've got travel prices going up it's
it's costing more to put a roof over
your family's heads as well as energy
keeping them warm and i think having all
of those battles
is putting on us on a path there unless
we can do something to be able to
actually stem the rising cost of living
across all these different markets and
anna does this feel a bit like i mean
for different reasons though a bit like
2008 2009 where we're on a cliff edge
i can't really answer that but what i
can say is that is absolutely vital that
we make sure that the very poorest are
protected because we are a compassionate
caring country we do not want to see
children going to school hungry we do
not want to see old people dying of the
cold in their homes and so we have to
make sure that no matter what happens
the very poorest people are protected
well said we'll end it on those words
really good hearing that thank you all
very much indeed anna stephenson really
good hearing from you gemma godfrey
lovely having you here miata fanbooley
thank you so so much for allowing us to
access the brain cells
really have benefited an awful lot of
news you can use information you can use
there